[Zene]
köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót és
nézőt a mai vendégem bence edit aki
pasztorál pszichológus és segítő
beszélgetéseket folytat valamint
coaching szakemberként dolgozik itt
székelyudvarhelyen izgalmas kérdésekről
fogunk beszélgetni mint például azt hogy
mi is az embernek az identitása milyenek
vagyunk mi emberek és mi az ami
meghatározza az identitásunkat
egyáltalán hogyan tudunk beszélni az
identitásunkról valamint mit okoz az
életünkben hogyha nem találjuk ezt az
identitást tartsatok
velünk szóval edit köszöntelek a
műsorunkban és nagyon hálás vagyok hogy
el elfogadtad a meghívást
mert számomra a pszichológia egy nagyon
közeli téma és rengeteg rengeteget
foglalkoztam ezzel a témával és
emlékszem amikor együtt is találkoztunk
úgy éreztem hogy megértjük egymást
félszavakból is értjük egymást és az
előbb ahogy beszélgettünk erről hogy ez
a közösségi média meg a kilépni a
kulisszák mögül ez mennyire egy egy
izgalmas kérdés neked is és és valójában
nekem is emiatt indítottam ezt a
podcastet van valami amit ezzel
kapcsolatban megértettem és kíváncsi
vagyok a véleményedre mielőtt még
belefogunk azokba a témákba amikről
szeretnénk
beszélgetni
azt értettem meg és gondolkozok rajta
folyamatosan hogy olyan minthogyha az
emberiség kollektívan azt a közösségi
médiát feltalálta és minthogyha odaadta
volna azoknak a deviáns extrém
személyeknek akik nem félnek attól hogy
hogy kritizálják majd őket nem félnek
majd attól hogy hogy prominens véleményt
fogalmazzanak meg nem van bennük egy
exib exhibicionizmus van bennük egy egy
nárcizmus és és valójában amikor én
rájöttem arra hogy hogy tényleg ez
történik hogy odaadtuk ezt a a közösségi
médiát mert én például csendben voltam
az elmúlt 13 év facebook aktivitásomat
ha valaki végignézi akkor azt veszi
észre hogy az elmúlt 12 évben nagyon
keveset posztoltam nagyon kevésszer
kommentelni szinte sosem kommenteltem
próbáltam a bölcs hallgatag
intellektuális figurát játszani aki nem
szól oda mert nem tartja méltónak
bizonyos beszélgetéseket és rájöttem
hogy ez nem jó rájöttem hogy nem jó mert
valójában a képét a világ a gyermekeink
számára adott képet arra hogy mitől lesz
valaki például sikeres nem én fogom
formálni hanem hanem azok a személyek
akik nem félnek attól hogy kritizálják
valamilyen oknál fogva nem zavarják őket
a a negatív kritikák és vonzza a
szociopátiát vonzza a pszichopátiát
vonzza a nárcizmust a közösségi média és
akkor ezekben a hetekben és hónapokban
az elmúlt időszakban jöttem rá hogy
valójában morális kötelességem még akkor
is hogyha rosszul csinál álom még akkor
is hogyha az
elején elelrontok bizonyos dolgokat
olyan
olyan amatőr módon közelítem meg akkor
is jobb amatőr módon megközelíteni és
gyakorolni és próbálkozni megfogalmazni
a véleményemet mintogy a kulisszák
mögött maradjak a csendben és az
idézőjeles bölcsességemmel megmaradjak
úgyhogy mi a véleményed erről az
nyitógondolatról én is először
köszöntelek szeretettel tehát köszönöm
hogy itt lehetek nagyon jó a gondolat
köszönöm ezt a kérdést ugyanezt a
véleményt osztom tehát folyamatosan az
volt az én elvem az én véleményem hogy a
kulisszák mögött maradni tehát annyira
komfortos annyira kényelmes és ott is
történik valami mert rengeteg
tapasztalat gyölt be így az évek
folyamán az évek során hogy történések
ejtődtek meg a kulisszák mögött nem
éreztem szükségét annak hogy előre lenne
esetleg szükséges jönni ilyen módon egy
picit izgalmas is most ez az
előrejövetel de úgy gondolom hogy
tényleg amit mondtál is megszólít engem
hogy a gyerekeink érdekében akár egy
értéktöbbletet hozzáadni a kritikus
gondolkodásmódot támogatni nem a
kritizálót a kritikust ami fejleszti
őket ami az irányukat előre tudja tolni
és igen valóban az van hogy nagyon sokan
nagyon bátran nagyon vakmerően látom
hogy képviselnek valamit és tolják előre
és tényleg nincs az az átgondolás akár
vagy bevállalják akár ugye bátor szívvel
a véleményezéseket a visszajelzéseket
tehát valahol valószínű hogy nekünk is
szükségünk van arra hogy merjünk úgy
lépni előre hogy az ami bennünk van az a
bölcsesség ahogy mondtad te is hogy
forgolódtál te is a falakon belül a
bölcsességben és úgy jól megvoltál abban
én is így gondolom hogy igen forgolódtam
de valószínű hogy amikor már közösség
teremtő értéket tudunk betenni akkor az
hoz egy nagyobb többletet ott egy jövő
nyitogató utat tudunk megragadni akár
viszont úgy gondolom egy picit ez az én
részem is nem tudom mi a te véleményed
erről hogy a bölcsesség a csendben
növekszik ki tehát ahhoz hogy valaki egy
picit előre törjön ilyen módon vagy
előrelépjen vagy akár hogy én is most
itt legyek veled tehát ahhoz szükség
volt arra hogy legyen egy növekedés
tehát az a mag ami elöltetődött az
növekedésbe kerüljön bele mert amíg egy
elöltetésben vagyunk és nincs meg az a
türelmi zóna hogy kivárjuk hogy be fog
érlelődni az a termés növekedni fog az a
mag valameddig már elért mert nem úgy
gondolkodom mint ahogy két évvel ezelőtt
gondolkodtam de végképp nem úgy ahogy
nyolc évvel 10 évvel nekem az a
véleményem hogy szükséges ehhez egy
élettapasztalat és a növekedésnek a
teretengedése
igen tehát a közösségi médiába kilépni
és magadból
megmutatni mélyebben dolgokat anélkül
felv lennél készülve rá az az az egy
ostobaság
és sőt kíváncsi lennék kinek mi a
motivációja hogy idő előtt mutasson meg
magából
valamit mivel én egy introvertált
személy vagyok ezért nekem egy könnyű a
a csendben lenni
könnyű könnyű nem felszólalni viszont a
amiről beszéltünk most az előbb az az
hogy eljött az ideje mindennek mindennek
megvan az ideje megvan az ideje a
csendnek is és megvan az ideje annak is
hogy elkezdjünk beszélgetni mert a
beszélgetés az egy kollektív gondolkodás
ugye ahogy most is egy jó pár kérdésről
fogunk beszélgetni edit mint
pszichológus
mennyi ideje praktizálsz itt ebbe a
székelyudvarhelyi kisvárosb most már 10
év van mögöttem ezen a területen tehát
igazából pasztorál pszichológiai
területek azok amiken nagyon szeretek
mozgolódni itt vagyok a városban és
nagyon szeretem érinteni szólítgatni a
reményt fölkelteni a háttérben ott lenni
készfelemelőként az emberekért az
emberekkel együtt együtt gondolkodni
együtt keresni megoldásokat együtt
keresni
válaszokat mint pszichológus is mint
családanya mint feleség még milyen más
szerepet említenél meg magadból
igazából érdekes ez ahogy úgy fejlődött
akár a szakmai utam amikor én elvégeztem
a pszichológia alapképzést kolozsváron
akkor én azzal a céllal végeztem el hogy
én pasztorált pszichológiai területeken
szeretnék mozgolódni aki későbbiekben az
irányt teljesen ebbe az irányba vettem
tehát úgy megragadott megszólított
ugye a pasztorálpszichológia a
teológiának és a pszichológiának a
kollaboratív kapcsolata tehát volt egy
pont az egyetemen is többször is akár de
egy bizonyos pont amikor úgy tudtam hogy
a pszichológia tudománya előtt tényleg
ilyen nagy tisztelettel állok meg ott
van az elfogadó szívem a tudomány fele
de van az a pont amikor megláttam hogy a
tudománynak a kap amikor lezárulnak vagy
nem elég csupán az a rész hogy a
tudomány ott még hátra van az hogy a hit
és ott nyílik meg a lehetőség tehát
valahol egy picit az útmutatás vagy az
útra terelődés irányát szerettem volna
még inkább beemelni vagy beölelni a
pasztorál
pszichológiával amikor elvégeztem a
pasztorálpszichológiát és már így
dolgoztam egyénekkel akkor
megfogalmazódott egy idő után az az
igény tehát láttam megszület igényeket
láttam megszületni
kérdéseket olyan módon is hogy minden
egyén aki beszélgetésekre segítő
beszélgetéseket folytatok tehát aki
segítő beszélgetésekre vagy supportí
beszélgetésekre jár jön el kérdez
útkeresésben van magával hozza
láthatatlan módon a családtagjait és
emiatt
a szívemet úgy megszólította az is hogy
egy picit szélesítsem ki a sátorzölöp
imet úgymond és kezdjek el tanulni
rendszerszemléletet és emiatt elkezdtem
családi és párkapcsolati szakon is
tanulni és sikerült lediplomáznom azon a
területen is és így emiatt párokkal meg
családokkal is tudok foglalkozni nagyobb
szakszerűséggel tudok ott lenni de
főként emberként szeretek a leginkább
valamilyen módon ott lenni és utána így
a szakemberi réssszel kapcsolni az
emberi részt miután ezen az úton is így
már járatosságot kezdtem szerezni és a
tapasztalatom bővült a következő lépés a
coaching és a vezetés területe volt ez
is igényekből született meg olyan
érdekes hogy úgy fogalmaztam hogy előbb
az igények jöttek szembe és utána úgy
megkerestem a helyét hogy mi az ami
mélyebben hívogat vagy mélyebben egy
hívószóvá válik számomra és amiatt hogy
a kompetenciakészségeimet még tudjam
bővíteni és még inkább
professzionálisabb odafordulással tudjak
jelen lenni és amiatt is hogy vezetők
kezdtek el cégvezetők vagy tulajdonosok
vagy olyan személyek megkeresni akiknél
azt láttam hogy ott szükség van arra
hogy én is bővítsem a tudásomat és úgy
tudunk összekapcsolódni hogyha én is egy
bővítettebb irányt tudok megragadni
emiatt történt a következő lépés amit
említettem a coaching és a vezetés
szakirány úgyhogy ezeken a területeken
mozgolódom kérdezted hogy még hogyan
nevezhetnél azon kívül hogy családanya
vagy segítői területen járatosságban
lévő tehát emberként a leginkább é
személyként a leginkább ezt szeretek a
leginkább lenni az egyik nagyon bölcs
professzoromtól tanultam meg azt hogy
hivatásból legyünk emberek és úgy ezt
szeretem hogy hivatásból embernek lenni
de edit vagyok úgyhogy oké köszi edit az
ember nagyon sok témát megemlítettél és
fogok el ezzel kapcsolatban kérdezni
valamit de úy a az egyik
az egyik ilyen mítos szeretném egy
kicsit így így feltárni mégpedig magával
a pszichológussal jaog pszichológushoz
járással kapcsolatban emlékszem amikor
én elemi iskolás voltam egy-négy
osztályban akkor volt egy új dolog az
hogy egy iskolának legyen pszichológusa
és úgy lebegett a levegőbe hogy aki a
pszichológushoz megy annak valami baja
van az beteg a az és és az egyik
osztálytársam el kellett menjen
pszichológushoz és mindenki úgy úgy
rejtetten nem tudtunk róla beszélni nem
szavak nélkül is úgy az atmoszférában
benne volt az hogy biztos azért
meggyogyós
és valahogy úgy teltek az évek nem
nagyon gondolkoztam ezeken de egyre
inkább azt vettem észre hogy magádnak a
tehát a a pszichológia az egy izgalmas
terület és ha valaki pszichológushoz
megy
nem nem beteg feltétlenül akár lehet
beteg is de lehet hogy az azt a
betegséget nem úgy kell felfogni mint
egy tüdőgyulladást hanem valahogy úgy
gondolkozok úgy gondolok erre hogy egy
komplexitási problémája van hogy annyi
minden történik vele hogy szüksége van
arra hogy valaki meghallgassa egy külső
személy és már önmagában az hogy
beszélünk valamiről az már egy bizonyos
gyógyító hatással bír
és azon gondolkoztam hogy ha ez tényleg
így van akkor elég szomorú számomra hogy
valójában a környezetünkben nincsenek
olyan személyek akik meghallgatnak
minket valaki mindig valamit akar tőlünk
és valamilyen motivációval mondja azt
amit mond
és és lehet hogy szükség van valakire
aki motiváció nékül mármint az egyetlen
motivációja az az hogy hogy hogy ez a
praxisa ez a munkahelye feld már mondta
hogy amikor elment a pszichológushoz
akkor az a pszichológusa volt az első
aki szerette őt és mondta hogyha most
cinikusok lennétek mondhatnátok azt
hogy mondta hogy az anyja nem szerette
őt mondta hogy ha most cinikusok
lennétek akkor mondhatnátok azt hogy
azért mert fizettem a
pszichológusomnak mondta hogy de az
anyám akkor se szeretett volna ha
fizettem volna neki úgyhogy visszatérve
az eredeti kérdéshez hogy te hogy látod
hogy a megítélése a pszichológiának és a
pszichológusoknak hogyan változott az
elmúlt 20 évben úgy látom hogy most már
teljesen elfogadott és hétköznapi az
hogyha valaki elmegy egy pszichológushoz
igen én is így látom alá tudom ezt
támasztani én 20 éve végeztem
kolozsváron az egyetemi alapképzést és
akkor ami volt tehát nagyon távol volt
teljes távolság főleg itt székelyföldön
tehát emlékszem hogy úgy is fogalmaztuk
hogy gyerekcipő méretnyi és külföldön
már ott akkor volt egyfajta kultúrája
úgymond és elfogadott volt itt rengeteg
változás történt az elmúlt időszakban
nagy nagyon sok minden hozzájárult a
változáshoz tehát az elején úgy
különböző címkéket aggadtak ránk
szakemberekre agyturkáztól elkezdve
mindenféle névvel körbe voltunk véve de
hogy leomlottak ezek a falak mertogy
elkezdett a köztudatba valahogy jobban
bekerülni hogy nem feltétlen szükséges
valakinek egy olyanfajta megbetegedés
létrejöjjön hogy tényleg a végsőkig
várnia kellene azzal hogy hú akkor
kimerül és de vannak persze ilyenek is
tehát ezt nem kizárólagosan mondom hanem
lehet akár egy preventív összedolgozás
vagy akár lehet csak egy elakadás tehát
egészséges emberekkel való
összedolgozásokat ejtek meg akik
megakadtak különböző nehézségekben
különböző krízisek hatására elakadásaik
voltak és behozok egy példát olyan jó
pofa volt egy fiatal személy egy fiatal
hölgy akit
nemrég ismertem meg mikor megkérdeztem
hogy milyen érzés ő néki hogy velem
szemben ül az volt a válasza hogy hát
soha nem gondoltam volna hogy ide
süllyedek jó nagyot nevettünk rajta és
az első találkozás végén mikor
felajánlottam a lehetőséget hogy ha
szeretné folytatni akkor jelezze
amennyiben nem akkor örülök hogy volt
egy találkozás és na hiszem hogy ennek a
találkozásnak is meg tud lenni a sajátos
értelme alig várta hogy kimondja a
választ így utólag megfogalmazta hogy én
mindenkor jönni szeretnék még máskor is
tehát mindenképp és azóta is úgy havi
egy-egy beszélgetésre benevez merthogy
már nem süllyedésnek odasüllyedésnek
látja hanem valahol egy fejlődésnek
látja tehát van egy nyitottság nagyobb
nyitottság és érdekes módon a férfiak
részéről is tehát az elején ti évvel
ezelőtt valahogy úgy fogalmaznék hogy
amíg 5%-a volt férfi aki eljött egy-egy
beszélgetésre és a többi rész hölgy volt
most viszont már azt látom hogy
körülbelül egy ilyen
35%-os férfi megjelenés van úgymond iss
hogy így bővül évről évre a nyitottság
vagy növekszik a férfiak száma is és van
hát az egyik ismerősöm egy másik városba
ment igen
pszichológushoz hajlandó utazni egy órát
igen azért hogy ne találkozzon senkivel
aki aki esetleg megtudhatná hogy ő ő
pszichológushoz kell menjen annyira fél
attól hogy meg fogják bélyegezni
igen tapasztalom ezt én is hogy kovászna
meg maros megyéből is hajlandóak átjönni
az emberek akár bevállalval azt az
utazást az utat mertogy na a védő búrok
a védőzóna az egy picit többletet is tud
nekik nyújtani vagy ilyen módon is egy
többletet tud nyújtani de amúgyis ugye
egy személyes védőbugyorba vannak
belehelyezve tehát be van biztosítva az
hogy tehát mtad hogy hogy direkt úgy
tervezted meg magá magát a a a a
folyosón való közlekedést is hogy
egymással ne találkozhassanak az ember
pontosan milyen problémával szoktak
megkeresni téged milyen egy tipikus
probléma ha van egyáltalán tipikus
probléma vannak
problémák picit általánosítás véleményem
szerint ha tipizáljuk vagy tipikussággal
ruházzuk föl a problémam megnevezéseket
mert mindenkinek valahol ugye a sajátja
a legintenzívebb és a legmélyebben
elgondolkodtatásra bí vagy legmélyebb
nehézséget hordozó amit érzékelek
mostanság tehát egy picit a kor is
magával hozta ezt a jóléti társadalomnak
ak kor tát tétje van a jólétnek tehát
valahol a jólét nem az biztosítja hogy
jól lét van a jó léttől fosztott meg a
jólét többek közt tehát tétje kezdett
lenni a létnek hogy egy picit így
filozofikusan fogalmazzak amúgy nagyon
közel áll hozzám a filozófia tehát tétje
van a
jólétnek nem erősít nem ad egy
biztonságot hogy attól amiért megszerzők
vagyunk leszünk értékhordozók vagy
leszünk azok akik a megszerzésen túl
hordozzuk is azt az értéket ami
megszerződött valamilyen módon tehát
egyik a másikra nem hat rá olyan módon
hogy egy ilyen győzelmi szférába vigyen
bele olyan módon viszont igen hogyha
megtaláljuk a létértelmet akkor
megelégedünk azzal amink van elkezdünk
egyre inkább egy megelégedettségbe
belemenni tehát kérdezted hogy leginkább
milyen problémákkal keresnek meg tehát
amit érzékelek és ide hoztam be ugye
magát a kort is amiben vagyunk hogy a
létértelem
megkérdőjelezése a kiüresedett lét az
amivel keresnek a leginkább tehát nincs
értéke a létnek azt érzik hogy belül
üres vájatok vagy üres járatok kezdtek
el kialakulni a létben a szívben a
lélekben emiatt is kezdtem el
intenzívebben foglalkozni elfelejtettem
az előbb említeni a logoterápia meg az
egzisztenciaanalízissel ugye ez az
értelemközpontú beszélgetés az értelem
és az értékekkel való
összedolgozás tehát vallja viktor
franknek az elmélete meg az ő nagyon
szuper számomra nagyon szuperül
kidolgozott munkásságának a hozadéka
vagy tevékenység ének a hozzadéka nagyon
szeretek ezekkel az elemekkel dolgozni
hogy van a sorszerű ami adatott és van a
szabadtér és megtaláltatni az egyénekkel
akár a családokkal akár a párokkal azt a
szabad teret ahol bebiztosítódik a
továbblépési iránya most az elején nem
biztos hogy úgy lehet érteni vagy átélni
megértelmezni hogy ott rögtön
bebiztosítódott valami de nyílnak a
terek és nyílnak a kapuk ahogy elkezdjük
a szabad teret megkeresni úgy szoktam
fogalmazni hogy mim van ami megmaradt
annak ellenére hogy tényleg van ami
elveszett tehát a szenvedő ember az
igazán kereső ember keresnek amúgy
gyereknevelési problémákkal kérdésekkel
pszichoedukációs tevékenység is egy
picit az én tevékenységem akár
párkapcsolati problémákkal akár
határkérdésekkel mostanában egyre
többenü válás a szülőkről tínédzserek
akár felnőttek fiatal felnőttek szoros
határok egy nagy egybemassza létezik
nagyon gyakran akár lehet félelemből is
és nincs egy különvállás tehát nincs az
hogy akkor elindul egy
identitás identitási úttörés úgymond is
az autonómia iránti igény ahogy alkotva
vagyunk ugye egy idő után hogyha
serdülőkorban nem kapott arra teret hogy
önálló indivídummá váljék a serdülő egy
egy idő után valahol megjelenik és az a
vágy ott van és előtőr és általában
fiatal felnőtt korra úgy átvivődik
fixálódik az a krízis hogy ott nem volt
kibontakozva valami aminek éppen
életcélja vagy időszerű lett volna
úgymond életfeladat lett volna különböző
problémákkal valami ilyesmi főként de
mondom a létértelem meg az ex az első ez
nagyon nagyon izgalmas kérdés amit
megemlítettél igen mert azt látom hogy
statisztikailag ennél gazdag abbak sosem
voltunk mint most a az egy főre eső
jövedelem ennél nagyobb nem volt se
romániában se a világon tehát hogyha
most azt nézzük hogy akár svájcban is
150 évvel ezelőtt szinte mindenki
küszködött az élettel küzködött a
természettel küzködött a
járványokkal sehol sem volt ennyire jó
az élet mint most a föld tehát átlagban
mindenki gazdagabb lett ennél több
tárgyunk ennél több használati eszközünk
nem volt soha és ennél nagyobb
kényelemben nem éltünk akármennyire is
furcsán hangzik mert az emberek be
vannak állva és és talán ösztönösen a
negatívumokra koncentráló koncentrálunk
viszont a statisztikai adatok ilyen
szempontból nem hazudnak és emlékszem
gyermekkoromban is hogyha már csak azt
nézem hogy mi volt a hűttőbe ezelőtt 30
évvel amikor én gyermek voltam és mi van
most ugyanabba a háztartásba a
szüleimnek a hüttőjébe azt látom hogy
sokkal de sokkal gazdagabbak lettünk
materiális szempontból
és mégis meg tudom erősíteni azt amit te
is mondtál hogy ezzel együtt viszont nem
lett arányosan jobb az életünk sőt
minthogyha fordított arányban működnének
a dolgok tehát minél gazdagabbak lennénk
annál inkább annál inkább előbukkan egy
másik kérdés a céltalanságnak a kérdése
még megemlíteném azt is hogy
programozóként ezt nagyon érdekesen
tapasztaltam ugyanis a
programozók most amiatt mert egy
információs korszakban élünk és e egy
nagy hull hullám és a hullámnak a
tetején lenni egy mondjam úgy hogy
anyagi szempontból egy kedvező dolog
emlékszem az én kezdőfizetésem nagyobb
volt mint a szüleim és a testvéremnek az
összfizetése és ez ez
rengeteg rengeteg morális
kérdést dobott fel bennem nagyon sokat
gondolkoztam hogy szabad-e nekem ennyit
keresni
20usonévesen és azt láttam hogy a
környezetemben ugyanez a kérdés felmerül
a többi programozónak az életébe hogy ez
ez helyese így és ezzel együtt
párhuzamosan azt is láttam hogy talán a
programozóknál hamarabb jelentkezik az a
kérdés ami jelentkezik amúgy mindenhol
hogy oké most már megengedhetem magamnak
hogy hogy elutazzak ide megengedhetem
azt hogy mondjam úgy hogy a az anyagi
hétköznapi világ sokkal egyszerűbbé vált
a programozók számára és egyből beomlott
a céltalanság kérdése beomlott akkor
most mit kezdjünk ezzel az egésszel ha
már nem nem azért küzdök hogy eltartsam
a családom ha nem azért küzdök hogy hogy
étel legyen az asztalon akkor miért
küzdök és akkor akkor akkor valójában
felmerül ez a kérdés hogy miért is
küszködünk itt tehát hogy ha a
materiális jólét nem vezet
egy egy egisztenciális
jóléthez akkor mi vezet szerinted mi
vezet annyira jó a kérdés meg úgy az
egész
felvezetésed ahogy mondtad ugye hogy
téged megszólított az ah hogy a szülei
nél nagyobb lett neked a fizetésed és
hogy itt a kérdésedet ahogy fölteszed
hogy mi vezet ahhoz a jóléthez ami tudja
biztosítani azt hogy ne pusztán ez a
tétje legyen a létnek hogy megszerzés és
a megszerzésen belül a kiüresedés én úgy
fogalmaznék hogy belső meggyőződésekre
van szükségünk ahol valahol az
istenkapcsolatból származik tehát az
ahogy mi teremtettünk vagy ahonnan mi
vétettünk tehát ha az az odakapcs ódás
megtörténik betöltetik a lét a létnek
adatik egy olyan értelem ami átölelő
értelembe visz bele tehát lesz remény
élő remény lesz egy kontaktus egy olyan
kontaktus ami nyitogatja az ösvényeinket
nyitogat valamit hogy nem egyedül
hordozom a terheket ugye akár hogyha
megemlítem azt hogy minden gondotokat
őre elvessétek mert néki gondja van
rátok tehát ez egy alátámasztása annak
hogy az isten foglal kozik az emberrel
tuugye a kérdés az hogy nyitom-e a
szívem arra hogy higgyem azt és
elfogadjam azt hogy tényleg az az isten
ahonnan vétettem ahonnan származom vagy
aki tervezett engem ilyen módon tud
foglalkozni tehát a személyes
kapcsolódás én azt érzékelem hogy a
személyes kapcsolódás hiánya tehát az
istentől való távolság a távollétünk
hozza azt hogy valamit mégis szükséges
űrpótlásokként betöltenünk és ezért van
az hogy nitunk jobban kifele afele hogy
megszerzés matéria satöbbi de viszont
amikor a kiüresedésnek a mézátonja ott
van a szívben akkor csak az az űr amivel
mi alkotva vagyunk azzal tölthetőbe h
valahol van az az összekapcsolódási pont
ez érdekes hogy azt mondod hogy alkotva
vagyunk és hogy ez ez miért miért miért
látod úgy hogy valamiért létezünk ezen a
földön miért kell valamiért
létezzünk miért miért nem egyszerűen
csak vagyunk kaotikusan ezen a
sárbolygón és egy milliárd év múlva
teljesen mindegy lesz hogy léteztünk-e
vagy
nem miért nem a céltalanság a nagyobb
realitás mint ahogy ahogy mondod hogy
hogy okkal vagyunk itt olyan érdekes
ahogy kérdezed ugye hogy miért nem a
céltalanság a valódiság tehát a cél
mindig felülíri a céltalanságot tehát az
ok az okozati összefüggés akár az ugye
hogy már az anyamében láttalak ahogy
alkottalak egy picit parafrazálom most a
fordítását az igének de már tervem volt
azzal ahogy téged
alkottalak nem lenne az úti célunk
világos most érds jól hogyha nem lenne
ott az hogy céllal vétettünk ha nem
tudom hogy melelyik irányba halad az én
vitorlám nem tudnám hogy mi a cél tehát
a vitorlám irányá hát ha engedem hogy
meghatározza azt hogy céllal vagyok én
itt a földön akkor nagyobb perspektíva
nyílik meg és jobban tudunk kifele
nyúlni akár a társadalom szívébe
benyúlni jobban tudunk megmutatni valami
olyat ami a belső meggyőződések irányát
erősíti mert amit érzékelek ugye ez a
materiális megszerzői társadalmi szféra
valahol a külső irányokat erősíti de
nagyon sok ember például ugye az előbb
kérdezted hogy mikkel jönnek leginkább
mikkel kell esnek meg milyen
problémákkal é így eszembe jutott akár
az is hogy
kapcsolatnélküliségek és a magány
problémája is felerősödött tehát
elmondják hogy nincsenek igaz barátok
nincsen aki őket meghallgatja nincsenek
még kapcsolódások nincsenek szívtől
szívig való bedobbanások valahogy úgy
fogalmaznak nagyon gyakran hogy nincs az
az ember aki őket értené és nagyon
gyakran úgy jönnek el hogy lehet hogy
csak arra van szükség hogy őket valaki
validálja hogy őket valaki emelje már
megvan az az intellektuális tudás az a
rálátás amivel ők jönnek amire ők
válaszokat kerestek mert ugye annyi
lehetőség adatik hogy utánanézni
bármilyen tanításnak vagy bármilyen
információkat megszerezni vagy
információt az adott területen belül de
hogyha van egy élő személyes találkozás
is többen keresnek így hogy csak arra
volt szüksége hogy tényleg elmondjam
hogy ő ahogy lássa az teljesen
természetes és helyénvaló és ahogy ő a
keresésében benne van adjon teret annak
hogy ő lehet így benne a keresésében
tehát nem a tudszatosítás és ugye a
társadalmi szféra valahol a megszerzői
szféra pont ezt a tucatosított
gondolkodást mert megérdemlem szerezzem
meg minél többet halmozzak föl minél
többet de ha halmozó vagyok a belső
hangom valahol hangosan kiállt kifele
kiált és a halmozás nélküliségben
viszont a csöndön meg tud szólalni és
ami mikor a csendem szóllal akkor lehet
hogy mélyen belülről titkok ismerőivé
válok tehát ugye a bölcsesség vagy akár
az istenkapcsolat titkainak megismerőivé
igen ami ami tetszett abban amit mondtál
az az
hogy én is amúgy szeretek vezetés
elmélettel foglalkozni és az egyik dolog
amire
rájöttem hogy ha nincs az embernek egy
célja akkor minden kaotikussá válik az
élet
hogy a cél az nem egy opció
mert kicsit távolabbról indítok de
megérkezünk oda és kíváncsi vagyok a
véleményedre hogy mi a véleményed erről
a
gondolatról annyira komplex a világunk
hogy egyszerűen a látás önmagában egy
csoda hogy az ember képes látni
vizuálisan képes felfogni a környezetét
a és pedig annyira komplex a a látásunk
hogy körülbelül az agyunk fele ezzel van
elfoglalva hogy lássunk nagyon nagyon
nagyon intenzív a a a energiaigényes
dolog a látás sőt nem tudom hogy hogy
ezt tudták-e a hallgatók vagy tudtad-e
te de annyira kevés dolgot látunk
konkrétan hogy egyrészt egy nagyon kicsi
szűk köröcskében fókuszáltan látunk és a
többi az egy
elmosódott kép amit amit így felfogunk
sőt van két vakfoltunk is ami ah ahol
nem látunk ezt le lehet ellenőrizni
hogyha fogunk egy két kört rára rjzolunk
egy egy egy lapra és az egyik szemünket
betakarjuk és elkezdjük közelíteni azt a
a a lapot akkor eltűnik az egyik kör
tehát hogy van két hely ahol nem is
látunk és mégsem tudjuk hogy nem látunk
és sőt nem is látunk színesbe a
perifériánkon tehát ennyire limitált
mert így mindenhol nem tudunk
fókuszáltan látni túl intenzív lenne egy
nagyon-nagyon szűk kicsi részen mégis
nem ez az érzetünk hanem az agyunk
kiegészíti a memóriánkkal kiegészíti a a
hitünkkel mit hisz k a világról és ez
azért fontos mert erre a komplexitásra
akkor jöttünk rá amikor a 60-as években
a mesterséges intelligencia elkezdett
fejlődni és akkor mindenki hurrá
optimizmussal mondta hogy még 10 év és
általános mesterséges intelligenciánk
lesz vagyis egy olyan mesterséges
intelligenciá am nem specializált tehát
nem sakkozni tud hanem általánosan képes
a világot felfogni és amikor elkezdtek
foglalkozni a a a
képfelismeréssel akkor jöttek rá hogy
ez egy megoldhatatlannak látszó probléma
hogy az hogy hogy látunk az mekkoraai
egy csoda valójában hogy mert van egy
ilyen keretprobléma úgy nevezik és ha
látunk valamit a keret az ami
befolyásolja milyen kontextusban van az
amit látunk az befolyásolja mit fogunk
felfogni mit mit fogunk látni azon a
képen ez egy ez egy hihetetlenül
hihetetlenül komplex dolog amit
gyakorlatilag egy gyermek egy csecsemű
folyamatosan tanul megtanul látni
úgy látunk hogy amikor a
világot tapasztaljuk akkor valójában
minden dolgot három kategóriába rakunk
van az első kategória ami minden ami a
célunk
[Zene]
elérése eléréséhez szükséges ez egy
nagyon-nagyon kicsi kategória mert
valójában kevés dolog van az ami segít
minket a célunkba van egy hasonlóan
kicsi kategória minden ami minket
akadályoz abb hogy hogy elérjük a
célunkat és ott van utána a harmadik
kategória ami mindent tartalmaz ami ami
minden ami irreleváns és rá kellett
jöjjek hogy ezt tényleg így van
emlékszem hogy a kauflandba mentem
és addig a polcokat ahogy néztem azt
láttam hogy hogy én egy torkos valaki
vagyok és a a az ilyen chipszes polcok
így világítottak a a kauflandba ugye
ahogy bementem úgy éreztem hogy minden
akadály és van egy csipszes polc ami a
cél amit el kell érni és vannak
irreleváns dolgok amiket amiket ott nem
is kell figyeljek rá tehát a pókafalon
vagy a a tűzjelzőszenzor nem érdekes
viszont a polc h a másik polc ami
akadály nekem az ki kell kerüljem és
emlékszem hogy elkezdtem utána
tudatosabban étkezni egy évvel később
meg kellett tanuljak leszokni ezekről a
chipszekről és azt vettem észre hogy
érdekes módon a cipszes polc kezdett
akadályáválni úgy spontánul és a salátás
bió mindenféle furcsa polc kezdett
hirtelen cél cél
feltűnni szóval ezt az egész körítést
bevezetésként azért mondtam hogy hogy
azt láttam hogy ha az embernek tehát van
egy pár tanulság ebből amit magam
számára
levontam ha az embernek van egy célja az
átalakítja azt hogy hogyan látja a
világot
így szoktuk mondani hogy a zsebtolvaj
csak zsebeket lát egy
egy egy kabáton és nagyon-nagyon furcsa
kategóriákat kezdünk észrevenni abban a
pillanat pban mit átalakítjuk a
gondolkodásmódunkat például egy ilyen
furcsa kategória amit hallottam hogy a
tűzoltók teljesen másképpen látják a a a
környezetüket amikor bemennek egy helyre
azokat a tárgyakat veszik észre amit
először kell kimenekíteni amikor egy tűz
fel lobban én nem ezeket veszem észre
viszont kérdés az bennem tehát hogy hogy
ha ha egyrészt hogyha nagyon kell
vigyázzunk hogy milyen célokat tűzünk ki
mert a célok átalakítják szó szerint
biológiailag azt hogy hogy hogyan látjuk
a világot ez az egyik gondolatom a másik
pedig az hogy vigyázzunk azzal mert a
célnélküliség az nem egy neutrális
kellemes állapot amikor se jó se rossz
igazából nem is kellemes haneman
neutrális hogy ülünk az ágyunkba és
minden rendben van úgy elfogadható hanem
a célnélküliség az egy elviselhetetlen
szenvedés lesz az életünkben szó szerint
az orientációinkat elveszítjük a
világban nem fogunk látni mert nem
tudjuk hogy mit kell lássunk te ezt
hogyan látod ezt a gondolatot
úgy szoktam fogalmazni hogy nem mindegy
hogy látok vagy meglátok tehát amikor
meglátok akkor látom azt a céllal
történőt nem abban akadok meg vagy nem
abba állok bele hogy miért éppen velem
történik hanem arra próbálom rávezetni
önmagam vagy ráfókuszáltatni a
tekintetemet hogy milyen célból és
hogyan találjunk rá megoldási
lehetőségeket tehát én a meglátás
képviselem nagyon ami a meglátásunk
alanya ami a meglátásunk fókuszpontjába
belekerül úgy gondolom hogy az kezd el
bennünket újból meg újból az utainkon
szólongatni az zárja ki azt hogy már nem
a csipszes polcot látom meg többé hanem
meglátom a biotermékeknek a polcát tehát
valamivel eggé válok valamivel
azonosulok valami olyat kezdek
képviselni ami felülérja az addigi
polcokat vagy az addigi akadályokat
nagyon szeretem megragadni újból meg
újból azt a célt hogy tudjam vagy tudjuk
hogy mi az irányunk tehát amit mondtál
ugye hogy a teljes neutralitás vagy az a
semleges ráreagálás mindarra ami velünk
történik tehát kiüresítődéseket hoz az
is létre tehát nem lehetek semleges az
életemre nézve ott a dönté kulcszó tehát
ugye elég sokat elhangzott az elmúlt
időben hogy a döntéseink meghatároznak
bennünket nem mindegy hogy hogyan döntün
például amikor egy picit visszaszálznék
az előbbi kérdés csokrodból az egyik
kérdésse hogy amikor én a
pszichológiával elkezdtem foglalkozni
ott tudtam hogy ha nem fog lenni egy
etalon egy mérce egy mérős zsinó amihez
én tudom igazítani önmagam vagy tudom
igazítani az értékeimet vagy oda tudok
igazodni és ugye ez nálam lett az
istennel vó kapcsolat az ige lett ez az
élő és a személyes meg
megtapasztalások területeiből beélő
történés satöbbi vagy megélő történés
akkor fogok sodortatni mert újból meg
újból valami úg fog létrejönni ami nem
biztos hogy tud egy stabilitást hozni
tehát vannak értékek rengeteg érték de
ugye hogyha nincs meg az a megfelelő
számomra megfelelő érték az a mérce az
ahogy neveztem hogy mérő zsinor akkor az
érték ől eltántorítható tudok lenni
tehát ugye újból meg újból kutatások
igazolnak több mindent vissza én amit
teszek a tudományos kutatásokat meg
szoktam mérni meg szoktam nézni az ige
mérlegén tehát összevetem hogy tényleg
akkor az ige és úgy nagyon gyakran
rájövök arra és tényleg így alázatos
szívvel próbálom ezt így megragadni a
tudomány meg az ige kapcsolatát hogy hú
hát de a bibliában erről már sok évvel
ezelőtt év századokkal vagy évezredekkel
ezelőtt ugye akár volt szó és hogy ez
már meg lett íratva vagy meg lett írva
és akkor hogyan tudok én ránézni és húgy
tudtam hogy ha nincs irányom akkor
nagyon-nagyon lehet kicsapongni tehát
nagyon lehet egyik nap egy értéket másik
nap egy másikat akár ugye most nagyon be
van
emelve a társadalmi szféránkba és
tényleg itt fájó szívvel mondom a
liberalizmusnak az elve tehát választhat
a gyerek leszel férfi vagy leszel nő hol
ott ugye az eredeti érték hogy hogy nővé
és férfivá lettünk teremtetve tehát ezek
az irányok amiket úgy tudok megragadni
és tudok igazodni hozzá tehát ismétlem
magam hogy nem mindegy hogy látó vagyok
vagy meglátó az értékeinkkel azonosulunk
amit képviselünk az kivetítődik olyanok
vagyunk mint a koncentrikus körök hatunk
egymásra ami kivetítődik belőlem az
tovább él abban akire kivetítődött és
adott ponton lehet hogy ott akkor még
nem fogan meg de rá valamennyi időre elő
fog törni az ami kivetítődött amivel ő
megszólítódott többször tapasztaltam azt
hogy évek múlva találkozok valakivel
akikkel beszélgetéseim voltak eltelik
köt év 10 év akárhány is megállítanak az
úton örvendezve mondják és képzeld el
soha nem felejtem el azt amit te mondtál
és ami nekik megmaradott és akkor én már
nem tudom hogy mit mondtam nem tudom
hogy mi volt az ami neki annyira mélyen
hatott ott igen tudtam amikor
visszajelzett a jelemben a beszélgetés
után de hogy benne még miérrlelődött és
különböző mondatokat emelnek be és nézem
hogy gyönyörű tehát rácsodálkozom arra
hogy ez élő szó tehát ugye a szónak a
tartalma hogy sóval meg tudom-e
fűszerezni és ugye a só maga az hogy a
hitet oda tudom-e tenni számomra ez hogy
van-e ez a kapcsolódás látom-e azt hogy
a céllal adatottság vagy látom az
akadályokat amit lehet szükséges
átugrani de úgy tudok akadály átugró
lenni ha érték képviseletben vagyok
benne és odateszem magam ahhoz az
értékhez szorosan kapcsolódom ahhoz az
értékhez ha tetszik ez az epizód akkor
kérlek iratkozz fel a csatornánkra vagy
írd meg kommentbe hogy milyen más
témáról hallanál még szívesen igen
többször említetted az isten
kapcsolatodat mint mérce mint mérőzsinór
el meg lehet mérni valaminek a az igazi
értékét és egy picit szeretném az ördög
ügyvédjét játszani ezzel kapcsolatban
amúgy egyetértek ezzel viszont ahhoz
hogy tovább tudjunk menni és egyéb
komplexebb kérdésekről beszéljünk azért
mégis csak fel kell tegyem ezt a kérdést
hogy ebben a posztmodern világban pont
az egyik érv az hogy valaminek nincs egy
interpretációja egy könyvet nem lehet
csak egyféleképpen ér érteni hanem
sokféleképpen lehet érteni és mindegyik
nézőponttal toleránsak kell
legyünk ha valaki úgy akarja érteni azt
a könyvet akkor ki vagyok én hogy
megmondjam hogy az ő értelmezése
alacsonyabb rendű-e mint az én
értelmezésem és ugyanígy érvényes ez is
hogy ha valaki eltévedt az életében és
szüksége van
segítségre mondhatjuk-e azt hogy hogy a
a kereszténység az a mérőzsinor ami az
egyetlen interpretációja az ő kiútjának
hogyha keresi a válaszokat akkor
valójában a kereszténységben fogja
megkapni valójában erről beszélgettünk
most az előbb hogy nem-e lehet hogy
ugyanúgy van sokféle más válasz és
egyenértékű mindegyik
válasz mi van hogyha valaki a a gája
hitben kapná meg valaki egy ősi
elfeledett törzsi kultúrában kapná meg
valaki a nihilizmusban az ateizmusban
kapná meg szóval sorolhatnám még a a
különböző ideológiákat is ide tartozik
most például ez a
balliberális ideológia is amit amit most
így ez egy egy neomarxizmus ami ami
nyugaton végigsöpör mi van akkor hogyha
abban fogja megtalálni és megkaphatja-e
és egyenértékűe a kereszt éggel hogyha
kap is egy másik
választ köszi szépen a kérdést tudtam
hogy nem fog ennyire gördülékenyen menni
és egyszer csak megjelenik az hogy igen
oké köszi provokatív kérdéseket nagyon
szeretek hallani és hogy együtt
gondolkodni
ezen ha megfigyelted úgy fogalmaztam meg
hogy számomra az istenkapcsolat tehát én
ezt mindenképp emelem és nagyon nagy
tisztelettel állok az ember előtt és
nagyon gyakran azt figyeltem hogy azt
tapasztaltam meg hogy amikor valaki
eljön én hozzám kivéve úgy általában aki
nem keresztény tehát nem tudja hogy hová
érkezett és én úgy első alkalommal
elmondom hogy én képviselem a ezt a
részt tehát az életemnek az értékét
megriassza-e az embereket ez érdekes
módon nem tehát érdekes módon egyáltalán
nem taszítja őket elmondom hogy a hitet
és a tudományt kapcsolom össze nyitott
szívek vannak ott viszont azt érzékelem
hogy az a tisztelet ami részem ről úgy
irányukba kimegy az pont az elfogadásnak
a tisztelete meg az elfogadó
légkörteremtés tisztelete ad nékik egy
olyan lehetőséget hogy érzékelik hogy én
nem rájuk nyomok nem fejbe ütöm őket
valamivel hanem tisztelem azt akik és
tisztelem azt ahol ők vannak tehát hogy
nekem ez egy személyes meggyőződés olyan
szempontból a segítői attitűdöm részét
is képezi ugye hogy add egy védelmet
mert tudom hogy mi az irány nyom de ki
vagyok én hogy azt aki nem ezt képviseli
elkezdek ítélkezni fölötte vagy
elkezdjek akár elmarasztaló
gondolatokkal szavakkal menni őfelé
tehát meg is szoktam fogalmazni hogy ez
az én irányom képviselem ezt az értéket
ahogy már említettem egy elfogadó
légkörbiztosításba kerülnek bele amint
már ezt is említettem és amit érzékelek
ugye ez a pasztorál pszichológiai
tevékenység valahol a a pásztorzót
vesszük is ugye ő terelget ő tehát a a
pásztor ami a aki a bárányokat tereli
most ért zsoltát a szó legnemesebb
értelmében nem az emberekre mondom hogy
ők a bárányok mertogy inkább tehát érs
igen amit érzékelek ugye tehát ez egy
terelési tevékenység valahol tehát
együtt gondolkodunk és ezzel a
tereléssel vagy hogy érintek egy-egy
olyan felületet vagy egy-egy olyan részt
ugye ami az isten kapcsolatomból
származik megnyílik előtte is egy
lehetős és szabad joga van arra hogy ő
melyik utat választja vagy mit választ
tehát van neki tere arra hogy akar-e
ezen a vonalon vagy akarja azt hogy úgy
nézzünk rá az életére hogy egy picit
másként tehát adok teret erre minden
ennek ellenére te nem úgy gondolsz mint
egy útra egy lehetséges útra és te most
ezt választottad hanem valamiért az az
érzésem mint hogyha úgy gondolnál erre
mint az útra az egyetlen útra hogyha
valaki gyógyulni akar akkor hiába ker é
bárhol valójában neki egy egy
komplexitási problémája van meg akarja
érteni hogy miért létezik ezen a világon
és máshol nem fog választ kapni jó jól
értem hogy igen számomra amúgy egy út
meg nagy az út igen mindenképp viszont
amit érzékelek egy picit arra is teret
adok és mindjárt reflektálok ugye a
kérdésed mélységére is hogy van egy
olyan ige hogy van aki az öntözést végzi
van aki az öltetést de a gyarapodást
igazából az isten maga adja tehát én van
amikor csak öltető vagyok olyan jó és
annyira felszabadító az hogy az istennek
gondja van az emberre tehát én ha
érintem ezen a területen vagy a
pszichológia mellé ugye hogy a hitet
odahelyezem ezek kapunyítások ahogy már
többször is fogalmaztam itt a
beszélgetés alkalmával lehetőségeket
nyitnak meg ugye viszont ahogy látom
hogy az istennek gondja van az emberre
és a szenvedésnyomás alatt nagyon
gyakran a puszta állapot hozza közel azt
hogy az ember maga dönt úgy hogy ő
akarja azt a többet és volt olyan
megtapasztalásom és többször volt olyan
megtapasztalásom az évek folyamán hogy
úgy nem volt nyitottságuk évekre
visszamenőleg az embereknek vagy a
személyeknek több személynek arra hogy
esetleg egy ilyen út is járható viszont
amikor jött egy próba vagy jött egy
fájdalom emlékszem most így határozottan
egy-két visszajelz é ami íy nagyon
kiugrik a sok közül hogy volt olyan aki
elmondta hogy eddig azt a részt
próbáltam emelni hogy kitettem reggel a
szobám falára hogy meg tudod tenni képes
vagy rá tehát ugye ilyen pozitív
megerősítő motivációs gondolatok amivel
önmagába véve nincsen gond csak amikor
épp ott van valaki az ágyban és arra
sincs ereje hogy fölkeljen és esetleg a
fogát megmossa ott valahol egy többletre
van szükség és amikor elkezdtünk egy
picit ránézni arra hogy az isten hogy
gondolkodik az élete felől a szobája
falára a meg tudom csinálni mellé kiírta
ő maga nem mondtam ő maga választotta
hogy az úr az én pásztorom nem
szűkölködöm és azt mondja a következő
találkozásnál ez az egyén hogy és
képzeld el edit hogy én reggel amikor
fölébredek mind a két kiírást látom
szóal egyik ről tudom hogy az már nekem
nem elég és a másikról tudom hogy az az
amire szükségem van és edit úgy keltem
föl ma reggel hogy már volt erőm a
fogamat megmosni tehát ugye az emberi
erő
valameddig működik az emberi erőfeszítés
de hogy van egy végességünk tehát
sokszor megtapasztalom főleg
gyászolóknál hogy ott tényleg nincsenek
szavak tehát annyira mély a gyásznak a
fájdalma hogy van amikor csak a cs
időzöm tehát van amikor ott és akkor
szükség van arra a térre hogy egy picit
csak a csendben létben időzünk és onnan
valami szülessen és várjuk a születést
és elindul a folyamat elindul a
kapcsolódás és amikor látom hogy a
gyászoló bele tud abba kapaszkodni hogy
mégis mégis van mégis van továbblépés
tehát rengeteg ilyen tapasztalat
kiiugrik vagy akár olyan is gyakran
előfordult hogy ahogy a kiüresedett
életekre
válaszkeresésekkel próbáltak jönni az
egyének a személyek is ők maguk ahogy
belementek egy-egy keresgélési
folyamatban volt amit így javaslatra
tettem mindenkor javaslok tehát nem
utasítok folyamatosan ezen ugye a szemem
rajta tartam hogy biztosítsam azt a
teret hogy legyen egy szabad választási
készség egy biztatás arra hogy pontosan
lehetőségeket tárok föl tehát nem
odateszem egy irányhoz hanem a lehetőség
adott ugye valahol bennünket is az isten
így szólongat vagy így szólított meg
hogy elét tártam ezt és elét tártam
amazzt is a döntés a tied és amit
érzékelek hogy amikor
k maguk elkezdenek kutatni és meglátják
hogy van ez a láb van ez a mankó van ez
a tágabb lehetőség vagy a ugye számomra
úgy a teljes lehetőség úgymond akkor
egy-egy válasz úgy szület meg hogy
elkezdi hordozni az életet belülről
tehát mélyen belülről és már nem az az
irány hogy akkor azt keresik hogy hát
miért nincs értelem hanem azt hogy miben
van és hogyan van az értelem és olyan
mély átélések és átérzések mennek végig
így bennem ugye akár amikor említettem
hogy évek telnek el és visszajelzések
ahogy beérkeznek akár egy találkozásba
csak az úton összeszaladunk vagy akár
kapok egy üzenetet nem tudom hány év
után hogy köszönöm hogy ott és akkor
beszéltél nekem az istenről és arról
hogy az istennek terve van velem mert
azóta az élet irányába megy a fókuszom
és egyre inkább azt érzem hogy a
hálateltség az ami bennem megfogan és ez
az irány visz így
előre ilyesmi tapasztalatokról tudok
beszélni vagy így a kérdésedre a
visszajelzésem ez hogy biztosítani a
lehetőségeket tehát a választási
lehetőségre ráerősíteni vagy
lehetőségként föltárni hogy van út
vannak utak és van út ugye nekem ez az
út ahogy fogal meg ft az amikor meséltél
erről a mondatról amit a falra felírt az
ilyen motivációs speakerek amiket
mondanak hogy meg tudod csinálni és élj
a pillanatnak csináld azt amit szeretsz
és engem mindig irritáltak ezek a
mondatok és nem tudom nem tudtam
megfogalmazni hogy miért mert valójában
ezek önmagukban jól hangzanak és talán
igazak is
vannak ezek a manipulatív technikák hogy
reggel nézz a tükörbe és mondd el tíszer
hogy szép vagyok és mondd el tíszer hogy
ma pozitív dolgok fognak történni velem
és most többet nem ismerek igazából de
engem mindig valahogy úgy zavartak ezek
a a a technikák és azért talán mert
olyan hiteltelenek valójában ezek
működnek ideig óráig zuhanyosz
hidegvízzel menj és harcolj a napnak a
nappal kelj fel és vág neki és és
megcsinálod mert akkor leszel nyerte
satöbbi satöbbi ezekből lehet egy hegyet
rakni viszont amikor valaki felkel és
azt kérdezi magától hogy rendben de
miért miért harcoljak és ha nincs erre
válasz akkor egyszerűen nincs kedvünk
felkelni fogat mosni se hogy ahogy
mondtad és ez engem nagyon megérintett
volt egy gondolat emlékszem hogy
teljesen átalakította az életemet amikor
amikor amikor ezt megértettem hogy a
teremtés könyvében amikor isten
megteremti a világot így ciklikusan
minden egyes teremtési ciklus után azt
mondta hogy ez jó hogy ez jó
és véletlenül nem ismétlődik ez a szó
mert feltevődik a kérdés hogy tényleg jó
a világunk tehát amikor körbenézünk és
ennyi mindent látunk magunk körül
háborút és járványokat
és mindenféle dolog ami fenyeget minket
a lelki pszichés egészségünket fenyegeti
tényleg azt tudjuk mondani hogy jó amit
jó a világunk és a válasz erre az
hogy ez egy hipotézis ha a
isten országának az igazságaival tehát
az igével kezdünk el teremteni az amit
teremtünk az jó lesz ez egy ez egy
hihetetlen gondolat volt egyszerűen nem
nem tértem magamhoz amikor erre rájöttem
mert mert tényleg az van hogy én mint
cégvezető azt láttam hogy hogy jó
szándékkal legtöbb cégvezető jó
szándékkal indul neki és csinálja azt
amit mit csinál és a hétköznapi
forgószélben valahol valahol sokszor el
kalibrálódik az a az az iránytű és ami
teremtődik belőle még ha jó szándékkal
is volt teremtve valami valami torz
dolog fog születni képes-e az ember jó
dolgot teremteni ez egy filozófiai
kérdés mert valójában a 20 század
kérdése ez volt hogy képes-e az ember
önmagát megteremteni a saját értékeit
képes-e jót teremteni önmagától az ember
és teremtettünk 100 millió hullát
magunknak a 20
századbaan és akkor a válasz erre az
hogy ha isten országának az igazságaival
kezdünk el teremteni az jó lesz és ez ez
fú ez ez ez egy olyan gondolat volt hogy
akkor először is meg kell is ismerjem
ezeket az igazságokat a navigáor podcast
valójában hogyha a trailert megnézték a
hallgatók akkor arra a gondolatra
alapszik hogy vannak alapelvek hogy
léteznek alapelvek amelyek irányítják az
életünket nem mi hozzuk létre ezek az
alapelveket hanem meg kell ismerjük őket
és egyszerűen alázatosan megismerve
elkezdjük élni őket és hogyha ezeket
megismerjük
akkor csak úgy fogunk tudni jó dolgot
teremteni hogyha elkezdjük őket meglátni
és az anyagi világot is abba abba az
irányba
terelni hogy megfeleljen ennek az igének
és beszélgettünk erről hogy a szavaknak
teremtő ereje van hogy ha felírunk
valamit tényleg működik egy ideig óráig
ha felírunk olyan dolgokat is amik jól
hangzanak de nem mély de a mélység
hiányzik belőle és a mélyebb
igazság az az
hogy valami feladatunk van és hogyha
nekünk valami feladatunk van akkor fel
kell
keljünk csak ez a kérdés hogy ez a
számomra ez is ez ez vissza é
visszatérek újra hogy tényleg van egy
elhívásunk vagy egy illúzió az egész
elmagyarázzuk magunknak hogy van egy
elhívásunk és emiatt magunkat önbecsapva
felkell és végezzük vagy pedig a mélyebb
realitás az hogy van valami egyedi amit
minden ember kapott és alkalmas arra
hogy azt elvégezze és hogyha nem végzi
el a világ egy kicsit rosszabb helyé
válik és hogyha elég ember nem végzi el
akkor a pokol elszabadul versus hogyha
megkap megkapjuk ezt az elhívást az
mindent át fog alakítani mert minden
annak a fényébe fog feltűnni úgy ahogy
beszéltük a kaufandos polcok ahogy a cél
függvényében fog minden átalakulni
eddig egyetértesz ezekkel a
gondolatokkal mert végig í bollogattál
de de akkor felteszek egy kérdést utána
hogyha egyet eddig egyetértesz ezekkel
hogyha valójában a
te
alkalmaidon ezt a kérdéskört járjátok
körbe csak másféleképpen másról
beszélgettek vagy más szavakkal de
valójában pontosan ugyanaz a kérdés hogy
megkapni az elhívását annak a személynek
és az adott ott kontextusát annak a
fényében látni tegyük fel problémák
vannak otthon problémák vannak a
szülővel problémák vannak a munkahelyen
problémák vannak a a motivációval
problémák vannak a súllyal problémák
ezer probléma felüti a fejét de hogy
ezeket a
problémákat olyan kontextusban látni ami
egy elhíváshoz kapcsolódik teljesen más
átalakul mert feladatunk lesz feladatunk
lesz hogy megoldjuk ezt a problémát már
nem csak küszködünk valami sárkánnyal
ami legyőzhetetlen hanem azt látjuk hogy
ez egy epizód az életünkben amit hogyha
legyőzünk ha megoldunk akkor akkor
további kalandok várnak ránk további
végtelen potenciál fog előttünk
feltáróni h hogy látod ezt a gondolatot
hogy alkalmazható-e a te napi
praxisodra egy picit ha megengeded ezzel
a kérdéssel is fog foglalkoznék
mindenképp de visszaszáll nék az
előbbire mert itt kettő kérdés is
elhangzott az ajkaidról és akkor
összepróbálom kapcsolni a kettő kérdést
jó tehát ugye említetted a teremtés
könyvét a céllal teremtettséget a
satöbbi és hogy az isten azt mondta hogy
éme igen jó amit alkotott és a világunk
ahogy kinéz ez akkor most íme igen jó-e
vagy akkor hogy is nézzünk ki valójában
tehát ugye a teremtés könyvénél az az
ige hogy szaporodjatok sokasodjatok és
vegyétek uralmatok alá a földet
kérdezted hogy céllal alkottattunk-e
vagy ez csak egy elképzelés ez akkor egy
ilyen nem tudom keresés útkeresés bármi
tehát igen céllal teremtettünk amint már
az előbb is említettem de ez a cél úgy
tud kibontakozni és ahogy te is mondtad
hogy téged ott szólított meg hogyha az
ige fényében nézem ott akkor valahol
mégis csak a szóereje is másként hat
akár ugye a motivációs idézetnél vagy
magánál az igénél tehát egyikben volt
erő a másikból már kifogyott az erő
tehát ideig óráig tud lenni erő érts jol
bármiben akár bármiben mert tudjuk
képviselni azt így vagyunk alkotva tehát
valahol az élet irányába ösztönszerűen
hajlunk tehát a túlélési ösztönök
bekapcsolnak tényleg van amikor elég
csak egy-két ilyen motivációs 5-10
mondat de van amikor az kiüresedetté
válik mert nem belső meggyőződés mert
ott már nincs erő és ugye az amikor
megtöltetik élettel és ott belülről már
megszólítódik az ember akkor a céllal
teremtettség hogy vegyétek uralmatok alá
a földet töltsétek be a földet építsetek
házakat házakat szüljetek gyermekeket
álljatok bele akár ugye abba az
elhívásba ez most nem ig de hogy egy
kicsit ide beemelem az jutott eszembe
egy zárójelt megejtenék hogy minden jó
adomány is tökéletes ajándék fentről
származik tehát az ajándék és az adomány
amit kaptam a fentről vétetett a fentről
kapott utat tör magának egy idő után
tehát valahogy én azt látom a saját
életemre vagy életemben is hogy valahogy
mindig emberek kerültek mellém körém
akik amikor én egy pici megállóban vagy
egy parkolópályára félreállva voltam
előszólítottak vagy megszólítottak és
tovább delegáltak az utamon tehát így
mentorok akár vagy tanárok vagy
professzorok vagy szakemberek vagy olyan
emberek akár barát körömből vagy akár
rokonságomból is hogy úgy valahogy azt
az irányt ott amit én egy picit úgy
ideig óráig vagy valameddig vagy volt
amikor lehet nem is annyira
picit nem láttam vagy homály telepedett
rá előtoltak vagy megszólítottak ahogy
említettem tehát a céllal vétetettség
egyik része valahol pont ebbe ölelődik
bele a másik amit említettél hogy a
személyekkel kapcsolatosan vagy az
egyénekkel a beszélgetésekben ugye hogy
akkor ez a lehetőség így adott és hogyan
nézünk rá erre a
lehetőségre tehát a lehetőség egy
lehetőség mindig magával hoz egy
következő
lehetőséget amikor rá tudunk úgy nézni
nyitott szívvel hogy ez a lehetőség az
ami valahol termékennyé teszi azt a
talajt ami eredetileg lök bennünket hogy
így fogalmazzak az élet irányába akkor
tud az egyénné az egyénnek a részévé
válni vagy tud
beékelődni tud
mélyítődni ezt mi hogy érted hogy lök az
életváá tehát amikor találunk valamit
amire ki tudjuk mondani hogy igen én ezt
kerestem elevel lök tehát odatol az élet
irányába hát ha ezt kerestem akkor nekem
van kapacitásom arra hogy kibontakozzon
akár a
személyiségem nem tudom megakadt részei
vagy akár ugye az identitáskrízis az is
nagyon nagy probléma az identitás kérdés
akár és nem pusztán kamaszkorban hanem
felnőttkorban is nagyon jelen van hogy
ki vagyok én nekem egyik kedvenc
kérdésem senki nem ússza meg aki hozzám
eljön első találkozásnál ez a kérdés
biztos vagy maximum második
találkozásnál elhangzik hogy definiálja
az egyén önmagát ki ő és nagyon gyakran
azt tapasztalom hogy szerepdefiníciók
születnek nem az identitás definiálódik
hanem a szerep
viszont egy idő utánr meg tudom
fogalmazni azt is és megtudtam hogy a
szerep mintha kint maradna és bejön a
személy ahogy a beszélgetésnek a méségei
úgy nyílnak meg vagy a mezők elkezdenek
úgy tele lenni jobban úgymond akkor
elkezd a személy úgy nyílni hogy mer ő
az lenni aki mer lenni egy picit úgy
fogalmaznék az az eredeti tehát az az
egyedi az az egyéniséggel töltött
telített satöbbi a aki eddig félt aki
eddig lehet hogy visszahúzódott ugye
ahogy beszéltük hogy mi is a kulisszák
mögött és a facebookon semmilyen
megosztásunk nincs hát tényleg nincs de
hogy mégis ugye amikor úgy belemegyünk
abba hogy lehet hogy akkor én most tudok
egy hozzáadást egy ráadást adni azzal
hogy a családom felé elkezdem vagy akár
önmagam felé újra definiálni magam és
ugye valahol az isteni terv pont ez hogy
az új definícióink
úgy szülessenek meg hogy tudjam hogy ki
vagyok tehát nem kizárni akar valamit az
isten hanem nyújtani akar valamit az
isten most ésol kizárni igen azt ami
nekünk rossz de hogy az egy
összedolgozási folyamatból növekszik ki
és amit ide még beemelnék ugye hogy a
cél valahol pont az hogy reményteljes
jövőt szán nekünk és ez a reményteljes
jövő úgy tud felragyogni az életeinkre
nézve hogyha az igenek úgy születnek meg
hogy merem vállalni hogy az identitásom
részét most már tudja kép azt hogy
mélyen gondolkodó vagyok újragondoló
vagyok fragmentált vagyok egyik kedvenc
kifejezésem úgy szeretek nem tökéletes
lenni hanem megtörtséggel bíróként
meglátni azt a teljeset azt az épet azt
a szépet azt a ragyogót úgy gondolom
hogy valahol pont az tud minket mélyen
belülről szintén gyúrni megformálni hogy
engedek teret annak hogy tévedő ember
vagyok engedek teret arra hogy
rászorulok a kegyelemre engedek teret
arra hogy szabad újrakezdeni és nem baj
hogyha eddig nem volt egy konkrét
identitás definíciónk mert ugye változik
a személyiségünk az évek folyamán
folyamatos változások érnek bennünket
ugye említettem hogy az élett
tapasztalata hogy megyünk előre az
éveknek a száma tehát más meglátásokba
visz bele bennünket az őszhaj szimbóluma
akár ugye mint az ékes korona a
bölcsesség hordozása satöbbi satöbbi
tehát szabadúj definíció szülessenek de
mégis csak tudjam hogy az a definícióm
engem hogy határoz meg úgy határoz meg
ahogy kaptam én azt lehet a szüleimtől
de az lehet és elég gyakran tapasztalom
hogy egy torzított definíció a nem vagy
elég definíció vagy satöbbi tehát van
egy nagyon sok vagy vagy van elég sok
belső parancs ami belénk égett belénk
ékelődött és azok úgy tudnak felülíródni
a sikerül belekapaszkodnunk valami
számunkra olyan mélybe értelmesbe hogy a
definíció úgy születik meg hogy én az
vagyok akit szeret az isten én az vagyok
aki számítok én az vagyok aki úgy tud
előremenni hogy erőt kap újból meg újból
én az vagyok akit meg tud most már
mélyen érinteni vagy meg tud mélyen
szólongatni terelgetni az az élőszó amit
beszéltünk hogy ogogy a motivációs
idézet meg a az ige közötti különbség
ahogy ezt az egyént megszólította
ehz viszont ugye valahol ezek a
megállások vagy a
szenvedéörténet formáló ereje
szükségeltetik most ismétett zárójelt
meejtenék megszólító újból meg úó
legalább egy téma van a fejembre amivel
folytathatnánk igen nekem is nagyon sok
van ahogy te beszélsz én még így
kreatívan érted belemegyek és juj ez is
nagyon jó téma meg am az is nagyon jó
téma amire egy zárójelt ejtenék meg
igazából ugye az irányok amiről így
beszéltünk az irányz tehát az irány
képvisel engem tehát az irány mindenképp
meghatároz engem az irányolat a célt ért
pontosan pontosan az hogy én definiálni
hogyan definiálom magam az is
meghatározz engem és valahol ugye hogyha
egy picit nézem a makrokörnyezetnek a
hatását és a mikrokörnyezetnek a
hatását felelősnek érzem magam olyan
módon hogy mikroszinten ami meg tehát
aminek lesz egy hozadéka vagy ami meg
terem vagy megfogan úgymond az kimegy
makró szintre tehát ilyen belenyúló
karok valahol úgy érzékelem sokszor azok
a területek amiben úgy bele bel kerülünk
vagy belemozdulunk de akár legyen szó
családi életről sokszor úgy szoktam
fogalmazni hogy nem szükséges ahhoz
feltétlen segítő szakembernek lenni hogy
tudjunk segíteni tehát sokszor akár egy
családi vagy akár egy baráti beölelés és
gyakran tapasztalom hogy amikor rákérdez
arra és van-e embere az egyénnek aki
hordozza a terheit vagy válvetve ott tud
állni mellette és nagyon gyakran az a
válasz hogy nem nekem nincs emberem
tehát az elmagányosodásnak a kora is ez
egy nagy zárójel tehát nem feltétlen
szándékozom kitérni ebbe az irányba de
ha téged ez most így muzít nyugodtan oké
visszaadom a szót szívesen nagyon sok
minden mozgat de most tudatosan nem
kérdezek rá az utolsó dologra amire
amiről
beszéltél ez az identitás kérdése ez egy
nagyon izgalmas kérdés számomra ugyanis
én azt tapasztalom és azt látom tehát
hogyha most megkérdeznét valakinek
valakitől szerintem a hallgatók magukban
megkérdezték hogy én mire mi mit
válaszolnék erre a kérdésre amit mindig
fel szoktál tenni hogy ki vagy te ki a
te valódi identitásod és nincsenek rá
szavaink nincsenek rá szavaink mert mert
ki is vagyok én valójában nagyon sok
olyan reflexió ra van szükség hogy
valamiket tudjál mondani magadról de én
amit még látok az az hogy a dolgoknak az
identitását
a tradíciókon és a szokásokon keresztül
tudjuk
megragadni tehát egyszerűen nincsenek
más szavaink ha megkérdezi valaki milyen
az exarlbsnél dolgozni vagy hogy milyen
milyen céged az exarlps valójában azt
kérdezik hogy ennek a cégkultúrának
milyen identitása van és mit mondunk azt
fogjuk mondani hát ezt szoktuk csinálni
meg azt szoktuk csinálni meg vannak ezek
a tehát így tudunk róla beszél
beszélgetni hogy és és valójában ha egy
ember az identitásáról beszél akkor
elkerülhetetlen hogy a szerepeiről
beszéljem mert ezek a ciklikusan
megismétlődő dolgok hogy az
identitásomhoz hozzátartozik az hogy
családapa vagyok az identitásomhoz
hozzátartozik az hogy programozó vagyok
az hogy vezető vagyok az hogy hogy egy
podcast podcastet is elindítottam ezek
mind-mind egymásra tevődnek és
valamilyen céllal tehát nem
fragmentáltan léteznek ezek külön hanem
hanem
összekapcsolódnak valahol szóval így
említettél valamit és nem volt tiszta
számomra hogy azt mondtad hogy hogy ne a
szerepeidről beszélj hanem az
identitásodról viszont én pont azt látom
hogy a szerepeink által tudjuk
megragadni az identitásunkat aztán
persze lehetséges hogy a szerepeinket
úgy kaptuk valakitől és ha mélyen
magunkba nézünk akkor ezek a szerepek
kényelmetlenek számunkra vagy torzak
lehet hogy pont erre gondoltál hogy hogy
ha a szerepeinkre koncentrálunk akkor
félrevezeti a a képünket az identitás a
magunkról alkotott képünket az
identitásunkról lehet hogy fordítva
kellene hogy
elmélkedjünk az identitásunkról és úgy
alakítsuk a szerepeinket hogy annak
megfeleljen külön köszi hogy erre
rákérdeztél nagyon jó hogy kiemeled hogy
ne a szerepeidről beszélj hanem az
identitásodról nem így értettem helye
van a szerepről beszélni csak ugye
valahol az
identitásról beszélni az ahol mélyebben
már elidőzöm tehát nem szer definíciók
pusztán hanem a személy önmagát tudja
definiálni hogy én a szerepem nélkül
kicsoda vagyok önmagában a létemnek a
létezésemnek a személyemnek mi az a mié
tartalma és ez az elidőzésből jön létre
tehát a szerep van ilyen tartalom tudnál
mondani példát ami független a
szerepeinktől például ugye az a fogalom
hogy értékes vagyok itt többször
elhangzott tehát egy értékvesztett meg
bizalomvesztett társadalom vagyunk tehát
nem h ába hangzik el olyan sokszor az
érték az érték most nem rég
tinédzsereknél külföldön magyarországon
talán végeztek egy felmérést is hogy mit
látnak ők a
társadalomban és valahol a válaszok
között pont ezek hangzottak el
fogalmakként hogy bizalomvesztettséget
és értékvesztettséget és őszintén szólva
megszomorodott a szívem érintett is
vagyok merthogy két tinédzser lánynak is
vagyok az édesanyja többek közt és az
hogy értékvesztettség meg
bizalomvesztettség úgy megfogalmazódott
bennem kérdésként hogy én a felnőtt mit
mutatok be vagyok-e az aki merem
vállalni a valódiságomat nekik valódi
felnőttekre van szükségük nem tökéletes
felnőttekre és ha csak a szerepeinken
keresztül mutatjuk be magunkat és nem
mutatjuk be azt hogy de én ember vagyok
akkor valahol csak azzal van
összetalálkozás hogy a szerep számít a
tanulmány a teljesítmény és itt egy
picit a szerepek alatt kiemelném azt
hogy a teljesítményt is értem tehát
nincs ahogy most érts nem a családapa
vagyok és akkor én hogy teljesítek hanem
van amikor szerepbem merevedések vannak
hogy én vagyok a mérnök és minden arról
szól hogy én vagyok a mérnök és semmi
baj ha vannak részek szegmensek amik
szólnak arról mert az gyönyörű hogy ő
mérnök de amikor minden a körül forog
hogy én mérnök vagyok és azon kívül hogy
mérnök még micsoda tehát ugye az
identitásában megszólítani és most
eszembe jutt hogy amikor ugye a teremtés
könyvéhez egy picit megint vissza
szálaznék hogy amikor isten szólítja a
bűnbeesés után az embert nem azt mondja
hogy ádám te a férfi évának a társa hol
vagy néven szólítja és azt kérdezi ádám
hol vagy a személyt szólítja elő nem a
szerepét szólítja te a vétkező te az a
most elbuktál te évának a társa első
alkotáson bármi érted te most hol vagy
nem a személyt hívja elő és akár ugye
hogyha nézzük az újszövetségben azt
amikor jézus elhívja a tanítványokat
tehát mindenkor a szemét hívja elő és ha
megfigyeljük péter pont a szerepe mellől
lesz előszólítva tehát otthagyja a hálót
és a hívószóra reagál és megy tehát a
szerepet hagyja és a személy megy most
érts jól ú a szerf az másodlagos
valahogy úgy képzelem el úgy képzelem el
valójában és szeretnék tovább
beszélgetni az identitásról mert annyira
izgalmas kérdés hogy hogy még fel fogok
tenni pár kérdést de én valahogy úgy
képzelem el vizuálisan az identitást
hogy valami láthatatlan dolog olyan mint
a mágneses mező hogy ránézünk de nem
látjuk a mágneses mezőt viszont hogyha a
vasport leszórjuk akkor a vasport
kimutatja beáll egy olyan alakzatba mint
ami le felfedi a mágneses mez ő neek az
alakját és olyan mintogyha az életünkben
a példák hogy szerettünk ezt csinálni
van hajlamunk erre tehát hogy a a
szerepköreink a hobbijaink a az
elhívásaink a ezek úgy nagyjából azért
kirajzolják azt hogy ebbe az irányba van
egy elhívásunk ebbe az irányba nincs egy
elhívásunk és az identitásunk
hogyha ha kollektív vagy egyéni
identitást nézünk akkor val valójában
ezek a példák és akkor lehet hogy
bizonyos példákat ránk eröltettek és
ezért nem működik és akkor ezért kell
elhagyni például péternek a halászást
mert nem az igazi elhívása a halászat
posan
amit megemlítettél az hogy hogy isten
gyermekei vagyunk hogy isten
hasonlatosságára vagyunk teremtve ez egy
identitás de ez egy kollektív identitás
ez rád is érvényes és rám is érvényes
mit mondanál az egyéni identitásról
honnan lehet megtudni hogy nekem mien az
identitásom mit jelent az milyen vagyok
valójában és mi az ami engem szabolcsá
tesz és nem elité pontosan valahogy úgy
ragadnám meg ezt a gondolatot hogy a
megváltás is azt vesszük tucat de akkor
lesz az enyém ha én mondok igent rá és
ott indul el valami mélyenben mélyenben
történő hogy engem editté tud tenni mert
ott kibontakozik a terv tehát nem
mindegy hogy valamiről mondókázok vagy
valamit csak mantrázok vagy az enyém
lesz tehát az egy éni döntések alapján
valahol mélyen megragadható az hogy ki
vagyok én editként ki vagyok én
szabolcsként és az egyéni döntésekben
vagy az egyéni választásokba
beleszületik vagy megszületik már az
eredetileg adott válasz ami kibomlik az
úon és egy picit itt az utonlét kapcsán
is beemelnék egy-két gondolatot engem
nagyon sokszor megérintett hogy egyéni
identitás témakörben maradván akár hogy
mindenkor az újszövetségben a amikor
jézus tesz valamit nem épp mindenkor de
elég gyakran helyesbitteek
úton történik tehát útközben történik
valami ugye hogyha mi szemleljük a saját
életeinket szabolcs te a tiedet én az
enyémet tehát útközben vagyunk valami
felé tartunk valamit
képviselünk amikor jézus az útközben
létben tesz valamit tehát a történések
mélysége
úgy jelenik meg hogy például hozok
konkrét példát tehát a vérfolyásos
asszony története ott van a kílódása és
a harca több évre visszavezettető harca
és amikor meglátja vagy meghallja hogy
jézus közeledik az úton a tömegen
átverekedve magát oda közeledik hozzá és
megérinti a ruháját és erőárad belőle és
ott jön a gyógyulás vagy ugye itt van az
útközben létben akár amikor a vakbtimeus
vagy nagyon sok az emausi tanítványoknak
a példája tehát nagyon sok példa
támasztja alá hogy úton vagyunk a
fejlődés az igazi értelem az igazi hogy
maradjunk ennél a szónál akkor hogy cél
megtalálásnál a célokat szeretem
felruházni értékekkel és igazából ugye
az a cél ami ugye a szívet tudja
dobogtatni mert hogy a célon felül az
igazi értelem megtalálás és itt amit
akár az útközben való történés is megejt
ugye alátámasztja azt hogy szabad nekem
úton lennem és szabad nekem akár most
még annál a válasznál tartanom hogy nem
biztos hogy tudom hogy még most az
identitásomban ki vagyok val ha tudjuk
amúgy ezt lesznek van van végső
megnyugvás az identitásunkban igen ugye
érdekes egy picit visszamennék akkor a
vérfolyásos asszony történetéhez ő addig
vérfolyásos volt de utána és a vérfolyás
ág meghatározta az ő identitását tehát ő
számkivetett volt azzal hogy vérfolyásos
asszony megpecsételt volt társadalmi
stigmák helyeződtek rá elkülönített
helyen való tartózkodás akár ugye a
leprások történetét is ismervén egy
picit tovább lépek miután lett a
gyógyulása ő már gyógyulttá váló lett
gyógyultá vált és az identitásában ott
már a gyógyult vagyok ékelődött be és
érts jól tehát mindannyian valahonnan el
kezdünk lépdelni a gyógyulás van aki a
gyógyulás van aki a felépülés van aki az
értelem igenlés megtalálás irányába és
ott nincsogy ne változzon az identitás
most érts jól tehát az identitásunkra
való lállátás tehát ugye a vérfolyásos
asszony vérfolyásosból gyógyult lett
tehát valahol ez a célja így a segítői
területemnek is vagy a segítői
szakterületem beölelésének úgymond hogy
valahol az az identitás képződjön hogy
voltam valaki akkor ott az volt az
életem részét képezi belefordíthatom úgy
a jelenemen hogy nem egy veszteség
fókusszal hanem egy győzelmi fókusszal
most vagyok valaki mert elmozdultam
onnan abba az irányba és mindig az aki
vagyok meghatároz mélyen engem kérdezted
hogy van-e olyan hogy véglegesen
befejeződött érdekes ez a kérdés nincs
olyan tehát folyamatos keresésben
vagyunk és ha nem lenne ez a keresés és
a keresésen belül a megérkezés utána
ismét a keresés ez is kiüresítené a
létet na de bár itt azért fontos
tisztáznunk akkor valamit hogy
igen az hogy nincs megnyugvás és
folyamatosan változik az identitásunk ez
ijesztően hangzik ez az egyik és a másik
hogy posztmodernnek hangzik és tudom
hogy te nem így gondolod kíváncsi vagyok
hogy így gondolod-e hogy
h olyan mintogyha egy homályos
szemüvegen keresztül látnánk a világot
és valamit látni vélünk a világból
valami célt amiele hívva vagyunk és
ahogy elkezdünk az úton haladni
egy-egy stációban egyre tisztábbá válik
hogy az az elhívásunk az micsoda és
rájöttünk hogy nem pontosan az volt mint
amire gondoltunk de útközben módosul az
az identitás de nem válik ellenkezőjévé
nem az van hogy egyik pillanatról a
másikra pont az ellenkezőjét fogom
gondolni a világról hanem egyre
pontosabban fogom látni inkább a célt és
ezáltal vagyunk folyamatosan úton de nem
kaotikus ez az egész út hanem egy egyre
inkább tisztázódó és egyre kevésbé
mocskos szemüvegen keresztül fogjuk
látni a
világot pontosan köszi szépen még
számomra is egy picit ijesztő volt ahogy
mondtad hogy és akkor nincs megnyugvás
de van megnyugvás csak egy tisztítottabb
látás kapcsán vagy tisztítottabb látás
keretén belül tudjunk már szem élni és
ugye ide megint egy picit behozom azt
hogy vagyok halló vagy meghalló vagyok
látó vagy meglátó a kauflandos példádnál
maradván tehát van olyan hogy van
megnyugvás sőt beleékelődik úgy a
személyiségünk abba az elfogadottságba
hogy én ez vagyok az vagyok akit szeret
az isten az vagyok aki a teremtettség
részét úgy képezem hogy úgy töltöm be
hogy megvan a terv ha most még nem is
vagyok annyira teljesen kibontakozva
vagy bontakozóban arra a tervre nézve de
úton vagyok és a történések útközben
jönnek
létre eszembe jutott még egy gondolat
így a tervekkel meg az útközbenléttel
kapcsolatosan tehát a lassú lépéseknek
az elve nagyon szeretem ezt támogatni
tehát mindenkor pici parcellákban
haladni abba az irányba amit meg
szeretnénk ragadni tehát ez is egy
identitásképző állapot merek i lépésekbe
haladni nem nagy bummokkal változzunk
hogy rögtön és akkor türelmetlenül
várjuk hogy jó már a tegnapra kész lett
volna szükséges hogy legyen és olyan
érdekes ide beemelek egy gondolatot egy
kérdést igazából emlékszem a pasztorál
pszichológia tanulmányaim keretén belül
tevődött föl ez a kérdés számomra egy
nagyon-nagyon drága tanárom ajkairól
úgy
kérdezett rá az élet
értelmére hogy hogy ha az életünk végig
végigtartana itt a földön tehát nem
lenne egy végessége szerintetek lenne-e
értelme és úgy hagyott egy pici
gondolkodni való időt tehát a
hallhatatlanság pontosan ha itt lenne a
földön de hogy végig itt lennénk a
földön és nem lenne vége 8090 akárhány
éves
korban emlékszem hogy olyan mélyen
érintett a kérdés első voltam a ki a
kezeimet nagyon gyorsan emeltem a misség
hamar előhívta a válaszomat és azt
mondtam hogy nem lenne akkora értelme
mert úgy túl elolnunk mindent de így az
hogy vannak életszakaszok tehát vannak
olyan részek ahol most elidőzhetek mert
ifjúkoromban más az életfeladatom mint
már amikor három gyerekes anyuka vagyok
én ugye történetesen hogy az időskornak
ismét más az életfeladata tehát van
amikor gyökérverés ami minket érint vagy
gyökérverő állapotokat élünk meg de van
amikor már szányképző állapotokba
megyünk bele van amikor már a termést
ami a szányképzésből bejött az már
begyűjtjük azt már tovább akarjuk adni
ott már szólítani akarunk föl embereket
nemes feladatokra hogy vidd tovább az
értéket adj hozzá valami többletet ahhoz
ami most itt megjelent a világunkban és
nem úgy értettem ahogy hogy a
posztmodern kor hozza közel hogy egy
nyughatatlanság satöbbi tehát valahogy
úgy fogalmaznék még kiegészítésként hogy
annyira gyors információk korát éljük
nincsenek
elidőzéseink pedig a csöndben csöndül
föl az elidőzés válasza az elidőzésben
adott válasz csönd nélkül nem tud menni
egy picit úgy is fogalmaznék hogy az
információs
időszak vagy ez a kor amit élünk tehát
gyors impulzusokat hoz de valahol pont
attól fztd meg hogy a csendnek az ereje
és a csendnek a súlya vigyen bennünket
abba az irányba hogy milyen gondolkodjak
el azon hogy mi az én irányom hol tartok
most hová szeretnék eljutni ez egy ez
egy nagyon mély kérdés amit a
professzorott tett fel mert itt
valójában két dolog feszül egymásnak az
egyik az amit mondtál hogy tényleg a
csöndben tudjuk meg
a kérdéseinkre a választ ha mindig
siettünk valahova akkor egyszerűen
elfedi és mindig befedi a csöndünket
valami akkor egyszerűen az élet
legfontosabb kérdéseibe nem fogunk
válaszokat kapni másik oldalról pedig
ugyancsak a professzorod mondta hogy nem
élünk a végtelenségig tehát a
mulandósága az élet tragédiája hogy meg
fogunk halni ez folyamatosan kopogtat az
ajtónkon és látjuk és ketyeg az óra
tehát egyszerűen nincs időnk tévutakra
nincs végtelen lehetőségünk kipróbálni
mindenfélét tehát egyszerre van az hogy
kell egy célunk legyen az életben de a
legjobb célt kell megfogalmazzuk a
legmagasabbra kell lőjünk az életünkben
mert nincs idő arra hogy mindenféle célt
ami ami körülöttünk van tehát ilyen
szempontból van egy hierarchiája a
céloknak és és és folyamatosan a
lehetőleg magasabbra érdemes lőni
és kicsit még
beszélgetnék kicsit beszélget a
rendszerelméletről amit említettél még
talán személyesen nekem de minthogyha
említetted volna most így a podcast
elején is ugyanis az identitással
kapcsolatban mindjárt lesz egy konkrét
kérdésem a rendszerelmélettel
kapcsolatban a hallgató kedvéér röviden
elmondanád hogy miről is szól ez a
rendszerelmélet mi is ez a
pszichológiában tehát a
rendszerszemlélet igazából igen tehát
arról szól hogy nem az egyént szemléljük
pusztán hanem az egyént kontextusba
helyezzük és ugye az első leges ahová
behelyezhetem az egyént az a család
ahonnan vétetett ahonnan származik
nézhetem a mikrokörnyezetén keresztül is
a rokonság a felmenői vonal ugye a
transzgenerációs szemlélet ezt nagyon
közel is hozza de nézhetem
makrotársadalmi szinten is és volt
amikor nagyon picit foglalkoztam azzal
de tényleg nagyon picit mert aztán
visszaszálazam abba az irányba hogy
inkább nézem a családon belül meg a
felmenői vonalon belül tehát
foglalkoztam picit azzal hogy nemzetileg
például hogyan határozza meg azt az
identitást hogy én erdélyi vagyok vagy
nemzetileg nekem ez milyen
meghatározottsággal bíró történetet hív
elő és nincs ahogy ne hasson ránk a
nemzeti
identitásudatunk tehát valahol egy picit
ezt a részt is emelem meg megragadom de
hogy mélyebben megragadom azt hogy az
egyént belehelyezvén a családi
kontextusába és ott nézni hogy a
rendszer hogyan hat rá hogyan hatottak
rá azok a szavak vagy azok a rituálk
azok a szokások amiket ők begyakoroltak
amiket ő hallott amiket ő látott amiket
példaként
elééltek ennek van egy nagyon szép
iránya megíve többféle módszer is van
ami foglalkozik így a rendszerszemlélet
keretén belül akár az értékközpontú
virginia szatirnek a szatirnak a modelje
tehát ő néki a meglátása saját személyes
átélése nagyon közelhozta azt hogy az
értékközpontú modellel dolgozzon hogy
úgy fogalmazott hogy van volt egy
kondérjuk amibe úgy mindent
belehelyeztek kulcsokat csavarokat
kacatokat amiket itt-ott találtak és az
a kondér egy idő után megtelt és őt
megszólította valahol a pályafutására
nézve az hogy amikor a mi kondérjaink
megtelnek amit hozunk a családból
felmenői vonalból mit kezdünk a
kondérnak a tart t almával hogyan tud
esetleg az
kiüresedni a nem odajáró részek a nagyon
most értz jól a nagyon kacatnak tűnő
részeg kivétetni onnan és valami olyan
kerüljön bele ami ékessé tudja tenni és
az örökség olyan részét tudja képviselni
akár ugye egy átformáló örökségi
részként is hogy tudjam azt a kondért
úgy használni hogy amikor hozzáérek nem
feltétlen az a fájdalom törelő belőlem
hogy igen de nekem valami nagyon nehéz
volt és a nehézségeken keresztül
szemlélem azt ami történt velem és ide
egy pici zárójelt ismét megejtek nagyon
szeretek zárójelezni mert közben annyi
gondolat a szívemből úgy előpattan tehát
ugye megszületett az a kifejezés is hogy
poszttraumás növekedés tehát a
poszttraumás stressz szindrómával
ellentétben tehát a poszttraumás
növekedés is valahol egy picit ezt a
részt megragadni nagyon kedvencem nem is
picit nagyon kedvencem tehát a növekedés
rész hogy a kondéromból amit beletett a
nagytatám a felmenői vonalamból bárki
mit teszek azzal a kondértartalommal és
ugye a rendszerszemlélet ez hogy ránk
rakódnak belénk égnek belénk kerülnek
különböző szokások különböző
kijelentések és én azzal akkor hogyan
kezdek el mélyen bánni elbánok vele jól
bánok vele
bánok vele satöbbi ez is a fejlődés
irányába visz igazából ez ez amúgy
nagyon tetszik ez amit mondtál a
rendszerszemlélettel kapcsolatban mert
talán ez foglalja legjobban össze azt a
mítoszt amit a pszichológiáról gondoltam
gyermekként vagy egy-négy osztályosként
hogy ha valakinek problémái vannak akkor
ez a fején belül történik ez minden ami
probléma a társadalmunba az az rendben
van de a a a problémát azt a fején belül
kell megoldani vagyis hogy akár lehet
ennek biológiai vetülete is hogy hogy
valakivel miért van probléma de a
probléma az mindig belül van és a
rendszerszemlélet gyakorlatilag ahogy
ahogy megértettem az azt mondja hogy a
probléma az valójában egy komplex
rendszereknek az együtthatásából ered
tehát te nem létezel csak úgy önmagadban
hanem létezel úgy mint és akkor megint a
szerepek jönnek be mint családapa mint
munkatárs mint állampolgár és ezek
valójában egy másba
ágyazódva léteznek és egyszerre hatnak
minden egyszerre hat abban a pillanatban
és hogyha valamiért rosszul érzed magad
akkor valójában ezt az egész hierarchiát
kell végignézni és végigvilágítani hogy
mit hiszel a világról hogy hogyan kéne
működjön és hogyan működik a világ mert
az is lehet a világ kínoz téged
valamilyen oknál fogva a környezeted
kínoz téged az is lehet hogy egy háború
van az országban az is lehet hogy hogy
egy olyan általános
kép terjedt el és hitted el igaznak ami
nem igaz valójában úgyhogy ez egy dolog
ami ami miatt valaki rosszul érezheti
magát és akkor valójában ebből
származva van egy nagyon egy egy kép a
fejemben amit nehezen kapok rá szavakat
de pont azért vagyunk itt hogy együtt
gondolkozzunk róla hogy amikor valaki
megpróbálja megoldani ezeket a dolgokat
akkor
valójában meg kell keresse
azt hogy melyik az a tökéletes
állapot amit és hogyan tudja elérni azt
a tökéletes állapotot valójában a a újra
az édenkertről beszélünk visszajutni az
édenkertbe létezik-e egyrészt tökéletes
állapot ez a kérdés és a
rendszerszemlélet nyelvezetét használva
a tökéletes állapot az amikor minden
egymásra épülve tökéletes és kérdés az
hogy létezik-e ilyen tehát hogy
létezik-e egy tökéletes állapot vagy
pedig egy illúzió hogy valaha elérjük
újra a mennyországot és szerintem amúgy
létezik tehát ez egy elméleti ideál
viszont azt veszem észre az életemben
hogy mégis csak jutok előre mégis csak
képes vagyok arra hogy bizonyos
területeket meghódítsak és mindig
bentről kifele lentről felfele történik
ez tehát hog először magamba kell rendet
rakjak és
önmagammal kell elintézek dolgokat és
csak utána fogjak neki olyan
problémáknak ami ami rajtam kívül van
tehát utána próbáljak megsegíteni a
testvéremnek vagy a
szüleimnek először magamból induljak ki
alázatosan és utána ha az már
valamennyire működik akkor menni és
próbálni valamilyen társadalmi problémát
esetleg megoldani munkahelyi problémát
is egyre nagyobb terhet venni a válunkra
egyre nagyobb
felelősséget mert
a valódi identitása az embernek és ez a
az igazalmas kérdés számomra hogy
mondjunk ki olyan gondolatokat amik az
identitásunkhoz hozzátartozik hogy
együtt kollektívan gondolkozun arról
hogy milyen is az ember én azt látom az
ember identitásához az tartozik hogy van
egy elhívása hogy felelősséget vállaljon
minél nagyobbel felelősséget tud
vállalni vállalni annál nagyobb áldás
tud lenni a környezete számára és legyen
az a személy aki képes a maximális
felelősséget felvenni a vállára hogy a
maximális áldás tudjon lennél és ezt nem
lehet végtelenféleképpen tehát a
posztmodern szerintem itt téved hogy nem
lehet végtelenféleképp éppen
felelősséget vállalni amikor nekifeszül
valaki az életének és egy azt szeretné
hogy egy olyan harmóniát hozzon el a
világunkba ami jó amiről beszélgettünk
hogyha azt akarja hogy a világunk jó
legyen azt csak isten országának az
igazságaival fogja tudni elérni és úgy
fogja
tudni hogy egyszer isten országának az
igazságaival rendet tesz az életébe
utána egy tágabb környezetbe egy
koncentrikus körönként egyre távolabb és
távolabb próbál egyre magasabb és
magasabb szinten ez a jákob létrája ez
az ami összeköti a mennyet és a földet
és ez az ember identitása hogy az ember
az aki képes arra hogy a kaotikus
összevissza környezetet rendbe rakja és
elhozza isten országát ez hogyan hangzik
neked így ez a gondolatsor erre a
második kijelentésedre van egy nagy
igenem igen ez a jákob létrája meg igen
az ember az aki hozzájárul módon
létrehoz valamit az isten itt megjelenít
itt a földön tehát az eszközeink annak
függvényébe tudnak bővülni hogy mit
képviselek amint már erről tettünk
egy-két gondolatot egy-két megemlítést
jákob létrájánál ugye viszont van egy
mély történés tehát ott jákob a csípő
csontjára sérül és az az állapot hogy ő
bic és miért sérül ez ezt igen pont
azért szeretném egy picit így beemelni
ezt a gondolatot bicegő maradott és az a
bicegőség
úgy emlékezteti őt arra most ért jó egy
picit ez az én meglátásom meg a
pasztorális aspektus meglátása is
úgymond lehet hogy sőt hogy
megmaradhatok abban az állapotomban most
érts jól hogy hol tudom kimondani és egy
picit visszatérek a tökéletes kulcszóhoz
amit említettél hogy van-e olyan hogy
tökéletes mert hogy szerinted van két
gondolat indult be itt bennem egyik az
hogy amikor isten szemszögén keresztül
próbál álok
szemlélni egész életszemléletemet ak
köré építem vagy azon keresztül vagyok
meglátó akkor az elég jó tud lenni nekem
tökéletes de ha ez a szemszög vagy ez a
szemlélet úgy nem kerül közel ahogy
mondtad ugye hogy megnyilvánul az
rajtunk hogy az eszközök az isten
eszköztárát ahogy használjuk tehát lehet
hogy a tökéletes kulcsza a
perfekcionizmus irányába tud vinni és
soha nem lesz elég tehát nem mindegy
hogy az elég vagy az soha nem elég az
soha nem elég a perfekcionizmusnak a
bugyraiban van beleelyezve vagy
bugyraiba van belehelyeződve és ugye az
elég jóra ki tudom mondani amit ott és
akkor akár a jákobi történés is tükröz
hogy bicegő vagyok rászorulok isten
kegyelmére de elég jó nekem mégis hogy
azt érezzem a mai nap hogy azt a
tökéleteset én azt meg tudtam ma is
ragadni és meg tudtam valamilyen módon
úgy nyilvánulni a tökéletesben való
mozgolódásombaan hogy tudtam nyúlni
kifele tudtam nyúlni befele a saját
szívem fele is és olyan bölcs ez a
gondolat és köszi hogy ezt is beemeled
hogy először ugye abban a szférában ahol
mi mozgunk a pici szférába é a
rendszerszemlélet ugye pont ezt hozza
közel hogy a cirkularitásnak a kérdése
nincs ah hogy ne legyen hatással ránk de
amikor ott teremtek egy ékes rendet érts
jól mert engedem hogy az isten kegyelme
teremtse az kihatol tágabb szférákra
hatol rá tehát itt a kérdés inkább az
hogy a az elég jó állapotom a
bicecegővel ha összefügg és én merem
vállalni azt és merem kimondani nekem
van egy nagy éligenlésem úgy bitcegő
vagyok ez így elég jó és ez a
tökéletesnek ágyaz meg vagy a tökéletest
úgy ragadom meg hogy perfekcionizmusnak
a mélységét viszem tovább és az soha nem
ad nagyon izgalmas a szó használatod azt
mutat a tökéletest hogyan ragadom meg és
az a az a
szinte a vicces szó nem a legjobb szó de
mindenesetre szórakoztató számomra hogy
jákob istennel birkózott megragadta a
tökéletest és birkózott és pan és ez eg
ez egy hihetetlen gondolat
hogy jákobból izrael lett pontosan új
identitást kapott és azért kapott új
identitást
mert ő lesz a kiválasztott nép isten azt
választja ki aki birkózik pontosan a
feladatunk az hogy folyamatosan
birkózzunk a tökéletessel pontosan és
egyszerre kell az ahogy mondtad az az
elégedettség meglegyen bennünk hogy amit
ma tettem ha birkóztam istennel ami mire
a nap lenyugszik az pont elég de holnap
újra kell birkózzak ez a végtelennel
való birkózás ez ez egy azt hiszem hogy
ez a ez a másik megfogalmazása az
identitásunknak mert ugyanaz a kérdés
felmerül hogy hogyan ismerjük meg istent
isten identitás van-e identitása
istennek ez a kérdés és azt látom hogy a
biblia valójában történetről történetre
meséli el hogy milyen isten isten az aki
atyát sátrából kihív a pusztába hogy
résztvegyél a kalandodban isten az aki
kalandra hív el folyamatosan ez az egyik
történet van egy másik történet isten az
aki szól neked hogy építsd a bárkádat
mer az önvíz jön és becsap és mindent
elvisz ez egy másik történet és minél
több történetet ismerünk meg istenről
annál több mindent tudunk meg de
ugyanúgy magunkról is mert nekünk a
feladatunk az hogy bárkát építsünk és
képesek vagyunk arra hogy bárkát
építsünk és nekünk a feladatunk az hogy
kalandraé menjünk és epizódonként
újraadefiniáljuk az életünket oltárt
építsünk újy ábrahám minden egyes kaland
után egy egy oltárt épített és abszolút
az identitásunknak a része az hogy
birkózzunk a végtelennel keressük a
válaszokat mert van egy
elhívásunk ahova ha nem fogunk amiben ha
nem fogunk részt venni akkor az a
céltalanság lesz urrá rajtunk ami ami
egy elviselhetetlen
szenvedés pontosan megszólít ismét amit
mond az bicegő birkózó állapotunkat el
tudjuk-e fogadni
nagyon mély kérdés és egy picit ha az
identitáshoz lépek vissza jákobnak ott
új identitása lesz s valahol az
identitás mindenkor így jön létre hogy
biccegő birkózó vagyok mert egy
élethelyzet egy krízis egy nehézség egy
trauma bitcegést generál és az a kérdés
hogy kivel és mivel és hogyan milyen
módszerekkel kezdek el megbirkózni ez
tökéletes zárógondolat köszönöm neked
nagyon hogy hogy beszélgethettünk az az
igazság hogy fel se tehettem a többi
kérdésemet nagyon örvendek neki hogy
ezekről beszélgettünk az identitás
kérdése egy hihetetlenül izgalmas kérdés
számomra mert az identitás az amit
folyamatosan keresünk egy cég egy
szervezet egy család identitása pontosan
mi az és az egyik kérdés számunra az
hogy mitől lesz magyar például a magyar
mitől vagyunk székelyek de ezt most
tudatosan nem is teszem fel mint kérdés
hanem
kedves hallgatók köszönöm hogy ti is
részt vettetek ebbe a beszélgetésbe
kérlek írjátok meg kommentbe hogy
például mitől vagyunk magyarok mitől
vagyunk székelyek mit tesz azzá és
hogyha tetszett ez a beszélgetés és
szeretnél még több hasonló
beszélgetésben részt venni akkor kérlek
iratkozzatok fel és kérlek osszátok meg
ezt a videót ezáltal is segítitek azt
hogy ez a navigátor podcast egyre
népszerűbbé váljon és egyre több mindent
tud tudjunk közösen elérni minden egyes
visszajelzés amiket tőletek kapunk az
segít abban hogy egy jobb minőségű
podcastet hozzunk létre úgyhogy köszönöm
nektek egy kincsel felér nekem minden
egyes visszajelzés és várunk titeket a
következő epizódban köszönöm én is az
ittlétet és én is elbúcsúzom és egy
élmény volt edit alig várom évleg
közelebb még le tudjunk ülni és
beszélgetni valamint kérlek írjátok meg
kommentben hogy miről beszélgessünk
melyek azok a témák amikről szívesen
hallanátok editet hogy még beszéljen és
ígérem hogy ha kerülnek ilyen témák
akkor mindenképpen meg fogok szervezni
még egy ilyen alkalmat mert számomra egy
hihetetlenül izgalmas beszélgetés volt
és csak úgy megint elröppent 1 óra és 40
perc köszönöm köszönm szépen ha tetszett
ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket köszönjük a vekker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért épületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre